I'm ready to go. Okay, hello again, it is the first month of the year, the 16th of the month,
and we are cruising right along in January. So we had some questions that came in for this
Zoom call, and then we'll open it up. So some questions that came in. First question of the day was
wondering which strain is best for cancer? We're talking about strain of marijuana, CBD or THC oil.
And the main two main strains for marijuana are the indica and the sativa. You also mentioned
Rick Simpson oil last week's call. I'm guessing it depends on the person and that one should be
tested for it. If this is a Zoom topic before I apologize. So what strain is used? I think the
question is what strain is used? What's the best strain for CBD or the Rick Simpson oil? As far as I know
it's not distinguished. So most commonly, if you do research on it, it's indica that's used
for the THC. I don't think it makes that large of a difference because if you're
titrating out the CBD or the THC, I'm not sure that it's the strain that makes a difference
in how the dose works for a person. So that's why I don't think that you'll find a whole lot of
data on which strain you're using. Now it makes a big difference on the strain that you're using
if you're just smoking marijuana because it will have some different effects on you. Indica is
going to be more relaxing called sedative. And so it just depends on what strain you're using for
smoking. But for the CBD and the THC, I have not seen data on what strain is being used or what
strain is better for a person. So I don't have information on that. Second question. I just listened to
a video call. Dr. C did about enzyme therapy for cancer. I wondered if proteolytic enzymes or
fermented enzymes are available through the online store. So proteolytic enzymes are enzymes that
break down proteins. That's what that means. And the story of Dr. William Kelly is the story of
he was a dentist who helped heal his old cancer. He had liver cancer through using
Dr. Bard's protocol from the early 1900s which was high-dose pancreatic enzymes. And Dr. William Kelly's
enzymes that he used are continually being made by allergy resource. We sell them on our store.
But we don't typically use those enzymes. We have some people on pancreatic enzymes that are
pork pancreatic enzymes. And the reason why those who were a part of Dr. Kelly's protocol was those
were the only enzymes that were available at the time. So understand this was back in the 1960s.
There wasn't a lot of supplements that were available. The pork, the porcine pancreatic enzymes were
what he found available. And that's what he used. And he had good success with it. But remember Dr. Kelly's
protocol is taking 75 to 150 capsules a day. That's like a couple of meals in itself to try to
swallow those capsules down. It's not a very doable protocol for more most people. But we have found,
at least with kinesiology testing, and we found in real life the response of people using a good
fermented enzyme that digestimes is the one that we use most commonly. It's not a pork based,
which is really good because some people react to pork and cannot use pork enzymes. And it's not
simply a proteolytic enzyme. It's a bunch of different enzymes. Asterozymes is there is one of them,
but it's got about 11 or 12 different enzymes in there. And this has worked much better. It's a fermented
based enzymes. That's why I think the question came out fermented enzymes because I speak about that.
That's what U.S. enzymes is. This is a great company. They're made here in Minnesota.
It's a, it's, you can use a much lower dose. So we've had people test as high as 10 to 15 of these
twice a day, and it's low as, you know, just a few of these twice a day. So these are what I take
here to. So I take digestimes, not nearly that kind of dose. I only take about four to six a day,
what else they so. But it's specific cancers that are going to relate to digestive enzyme,
dosing, and a chemitime protocol. Typically it's going to be liver cancer. It's going to most likely
respond to it, pancreatic cancer, and some digestive system cancers like
bile.cancer, possibly small intestine, large intestine colon cancer, rectal cancer can
respond to digestive enzyme therapy as well. Those are what we found to be the most common
cancers that tend to respond to digestive enzyme therapy. But this is one of that we use
didn't pull the pictures from the store for the other ones. But premier or professional health
products makes one called painkreatic eight. That test tends to test second best and the allergy
resource group ones that are actually Dr Kelly's old formula are the that we have in the store as well,
but currently they don't even have anybody on those. So, but they had, they used to test good before
we had these. So, that's that that's enzyme therapy. So, we test people on that though. But
you can also take this the most common use of this enzyme right here is understand is to help with
digestion. So, enzyme therapy for cancer, you're taking that on an empty stomach. So, you're taking that
right away when you wake up right before you go to bed, at least an hour away from food. The most
common use of a digested enzyme on the market by far is to help you digest your food.
If you took this digestive enzyme, you know, one or two with each meal, it would really help you
digest your food and get the most out of your food, help you with constipation issues, etc. So,
that's another reason why a person would take these. Next question came in dairy. Tell me why again
that dairy is bad for cancer patients. Okay. So, this is just a little picture I pulled off the
internet and things that cows are exposed to, tons and tons of medications. I've said before, I had a
good friend who was trying to raise cows more naturally, they were more naturally minded,
and they let their cows go outside every day and walk around and eat grass and then they'd have
come in at the morning and and milk them and then they'd send them back out, have come in at the
evening and milk them and send them out and they'd be outside all night. Now, understand,
most dairy farms don't do that. So, most dairy farms, those cows are in a barn in stations 24-7
their entire life. They're very unhealthy. They're kept alive through medications and antibiotics
all day long. They're given growth hormone in order to produce more milk and then they're slaughtered
if their milk production drops down or they're beyond calf rearing age. It's very inhumane,
but that's not the reason why we take cancer patients off of dairy products. This would be the reason
why you shouldn't eat dairy products. However, one would argue, no, no, no, no, I only buy organic milk
from my friend, who's a farmer who's never given his cows anything like this. He treats them
like they're his children and they live in the living room and sleep in bed with them.
And I still say, well, dairy is a problem for cancer patients and the reason is because of this,
you see this picture before we refer to it. Dairy has a lot of IGF1 in it.
It also has hormones and a ton of amino acids because it's a protein source. All these things
stimulate this pathway called mTOR. Your mTOR pathway is a growth pathway. Go back and think
of the source. What is a cow's milk for? What is a mother's milk for? No matter what mammal they are,
the mother's milk is to feed a baby so that baby can quintuple its size and weight in a relatively
short period of time. And it does so because milk has a lot of IGF1, a lot of hormones, a lot of protein
to stimulate mTOR, to stimulate growth pathways so growth takes place. Do we want to stimulate growth
pathways and stimulate mTOR if you have cancer in your body? No. So we don't want to stimulate growth
pathways when you have cancer because mTOR onto cancer cells is just stimulates the growth. That's
why we stay away from glutilates. That's why we stay away from too much iron. That's why we stay away from
too much sugar. That's why we don't give a lot of folate products. We don't give methyl tetrahedral
folate and higher doses to cancer patients. It stimulates mTOR. So this is a great chart to
understand these pathways on why we would say you need to restrict your dairy. So even if dairy didn't
come up as a driver, you don't want to be eating a lot of dairy. So dairy is going to stimulate growth
in every single person. Very simple to understand that if you just really look at that chart. I'm
going to unmute everybody and open it up for questions. All right, so does anybody have any questions
out there? Dr. Connors, this is Deb Swartz from Ohio. You're talking about mTOR and dairy products.
You know, some of us are total vegetarians. How do we get vitamin A if we don't get it from
animal sources? Okay, I'd have to pull up vitamin A chart to see what it's in because I don't
remember that. What's your sources of vitamin A are? But there's other, I know there's lots of
vegan type sources of vitamin A other than your dairy products. So I mean, just think of, you know,
other mammals are not drinking milk beyond their, after their weed. So and you know, people will
argue that question. It's like, oh, I need, I need some animal protein or I'm going to shrivel up and
die and the muscles are going to waste away and a comment is just remember what a silverback
gorilla looks like and how big and strongly are. Well, they're vegetarians. So you could get protein
sources, you could get nutrient sources through plants. And again, I don't believe everybody in
planet needs to be a vegetarian by any stretch of the vegetation. And from a genetic standpoint,
you know, there's a lot of people that should be eating meat. So it's, but when we're talking about
dealing with cancer, especially in some growth phases of cancer, we're trying to, you know, get the
handle on it and get it into remission. Dairy really should be off the table.
Well, they, they included with A, D, E, and K for keeping your bones healthy. And the keratins,
I know, come from plant sources. What's a palpinate? I think it's called a retinol.
It's totally, you know, chick, yolk, egg yolks, butter. Are those like okay to
having maybe a tablespoon of butter a day? I, again, if you have cancer, I'd say, be careful with that.
Yes, a little bit is okay. We're not talking about you have to go completely crazy vegan. But
yeah, if your cancer is growing, I'd say, yeah, you need to be more strict with things. So
it's all this kind of sliding scale. So do I have to eat this way? The rest of my life is question
number one that most people have. Well, um, no, um, but you want to understand what is, what kicks your
cancer in a growth phase? If you go out and have a treat on a Sunday night under your birthday or
something like that, does that mean your cancer is going to go crazy? No, but does it mean you're
going to start saying, I only have one treat, you know, every day, um, you know, we start to get
access, you know, it becomes, um, it becomes a driver. So you got to be careful with that. Thank you.
I have a question about, um, nuts. I kind of forgot like there was a group of nuts for either
tree nuts or ground nuts. One of those were not the good ones that are good for you.
Well, the ground nuts, like peanuts and things, you have to be careful of, uh, different fungus
and afloat toxins and things in those. Uh, so that's the, that's the biggest thing for those.
Um, soaking them will help with that. I know some nutritionists that say peanuts were never supposed to
be consumed by humans. Um, I don't take that heart of a stance. I, you know, I do think they are a
food and yes, they do carry different molds. You have to be careful of that, especially if you have
some mold issues or people that have lines should probably have to be much more conscious of that.
People with cancer are not, that's not a bigger issue, a less mold or something like that was the
driver of your cancer. But is, is it like a toxicity or something that could make, like, make it
unhealthy in general for people? Well, it's really the molds that it could make it unhealthy in general
for people. But then you go, okay, should I stay away from peanuts because they have molded them and
I could have ended up with mold issues or the little bit of mold in a peanut is that, is that,
is that necessarily bad? Could it be stimulating my immune system to create antibodies against mold?
So I actually have a greater tolerance to mold. Do you know what I mean? You can balance that out.
Not everything that is bad for you is necessarily bad for you in small doses.
Isn't there mold in mushrooms then too? Yeah, there's mold in mushrooms. So if you're eating mushrooms
in from the store, some people that have mold issues and live issues. So they have biotoxid issues.
I have to take them off of mushrooms, off of peanuts, off of anything that could have molded them.
But a healthy person is does biotoxid issues. Eating mushrooms can actually help stimulate the
bodies ability to develop antibodies to that substance. It's the same it's the same theory
that is not is not a theory. It's a proven fact of why the thought that vaccines would work.
If we give a small amount of the substance, let's say the measles to the person and they stimulate,
it's it's enough to stimulate a TH1 and a TH2 which is a B cell reaction to the immune system
that then they'll create antibodies against measles. Now they'll have immunity to measles.
The problem comes in is that when you put it in a little vial at how much are you going to dose that
person with that amount of measles. If you give them a little too much, they're going to get a full
bone case of measles. And now you did it helps the person. You just gave them measles. If you give them
too little, then it doesn't stimulate any immune response to the measles at all. And they don't
create antibodies. So then what they did with vaccines is they said, well, we'll put an adjuvant
in with it. And that's why they put formaldehyde, mercury, aluminum, and all this crap that you get
pronounced. Well, all these different chemicals, those are adjuvugs that they have to put in that
vaccine because they put such a small amount of the measles in there that no one would develop antibodies
against it. But when they add the adjuvugs as well, then in a greater percentage of the population,
it will stimulate an immune response. And you're not going to develop antibodies against
mercury and aluminum and properly guy call and formaldehyde. But you'll stimulate an antibody against
the livid organism that was accompanied with that vaccine. In this case, we're talking about measles.
So then you hope that they develop antibodies to measles. And if you develop antibodies to measles,
and you have so you have circulated antibodies to measles, now what you're exposed to measles,
you won't get measles because you have antibodies against it, your immune system will be more readily
to kill it. That's the whole idea with a vaccine. The problem is it just doesn't always work that way.
So the percentage of people that actually develop antibodies to the thing that they're
vaccinated against is actually quite small. So all you're doing is exposing people to all these toxic
adjuvugs. And if they have detox pathways that are blocked, those toxic adjuvugs can settle in the
brain, can settle in other tissues and cause other problems. And that's that's what's going on with
vaccines. However, you're basically vaccinating yourself against bad things by exposing yourself to bad
things, get small doses. Hence the benefit of teaching your kids to go out and play in the dirt,
like you did as a child, is very beneficial because they're exposed to bacteria and toxins,
and molds that are in the ground, and their body reacts not enough to make them sick,
but there's enough in their bloodstream that their immune system fires a reaction to it,
the B cells fire a reaction, and you make antibodies against those things, and you've strengthened
the person's immune system because the definition of a strong immune system is you have a lot of
circulated antibodies against a lot of things. And when we live in such a sterilized environment,
and we sterilized our atmosphere, and we're not exposed to small amounts of toxins,
that you never develop antibodies against it, and you are going to be more susceptible to disease
because of that. So, there's my soapbox about speech about vaccination, but it's the same thing with
exposure to mold. So, I personally eat peanuts. I personally eat lots of mushrooms because I want
that exposure to molds and toxins, so I develop antibodies, so I don't end up
with mold problems if I'm exposed to them in my house, or in the yard, or in the ground somewhere.
So, is it perfect? No, but I want circulated antibodies to mold. So,
and other things, and so do you. That's the definition of a healthy immune system.
So, if they tried harder, could they have come up with some other
additives besides the toxic ones? Oh, absolutely. So, and it's really not even trying harder,
they do it. But the problem is, is that how do you make 10 million of them and send them out to
the population? So, the truth is, how do you know, you know, a six-year-old who's getting their
smallpox, the vaccine, or whatever they get at six-years-old anymore? We didn't vaccinate any of our kids.
But if you're, how do you know, every one of those six-year-olds in second grade are getting
the exact same dosage, whether they weigh, you know, 110 pounds or they weigh 60 pounds? You know,
you know, because our healthcare system is so not personalized anymore,
they're in a quandary. All right, we'll just put all this crap in there to hopefully
stimulate immune response with everybody. So, they're mass producing this stuff, and you can't
mass produce, you know, back in the old days when the vaccines came out, they used to vaccinate
someone, and then they'd do a blood draw two weeks later to see if that person developed antibodies
against the thing you've vaccinated against. And if they didn't develop antibodies against,
the vaccine didn't work. Well, guess what? They stopped doing that because most of the time,
the vaccine doesn't work. Why do you think these outbreaks of measles that took place in, you know,
every single year, which they blame the unvaccinated people, which to me is absolutely mind boggling,
and these outbreaks of measles occurred in the vaccinated population, because just because you're
vaccinated against something doesn't mean you developed antibodies. Therefore, you don't have an
immune, you don't have immunity to that thing. So, it's, I just have a hard time understanding,
why would they choose mercury when they could have used something else? Like, why would someone
intentionally do that when they know it's harmful? Well, because, well, you could get the conspiracy
theory of that, they're trying to limit the population growth, which is not really this conspiracy theory
more, because we already know that that's true. But, but they need something that's that's that's
a poison that will stimulate an immune reaction. You have to put some sort of poison in there that
will stimulate an immune reaction. Okay. So, any other questions? I'm losing you Liz.
So, what did you say? The right machine, what? The double bubble. Yep.
You're benefit to it having direct exposure to the bare skin. Yes. Yes, I would say so. So,
you're going to get more power out of the bulbs that so the only way that the double bubble or the
the zinger bulb is stronger than the have our tube is when you're touching it right to your skin.
So, if you want to get a greater penetration, let's say, your cancer is growing, you know,
faster. We want to hit this as hard as I possibly can. That's what using one of the other bulbs
right out of your skin gives you more power. Now, the negative is that you just have to be aware
is that you might get zicked with it. Some of the frequencies is going to give you like an electrical
steam. So, you can't be, it's not going to be harmful or anything like that. But, if you don't know that,
you're scared the socks off. So, you have to be aware that you're going to get shocked by some of the
frequencies. So, I never heard of that. We had a choice in the bulbs. Like, I was given a bulb,
and I never knew that there was any other ones to use. And we, there's, there's other ones to use.
If you use them, just the way that, you know, that they're on a stand like the double bubble,
that they're not, it's not, I don't think it's as beneficial. It's much clumsy or to use.
That's the way true. I really pushes them and they sell them that way. But, if you took that,
like, if you took the plastic sheeting off of your hammer too, would you lay the glass bulb right
on you? It makes it a much more breakable bulb. So, I do not recommend you do that. But, you will get,
you'll have a little bit more power because the bulb is touching you. The closer it is to you, the more
power you're going to have. But, you'll, the side effect is that you're going to probably get zigged
too. So, you know, it's not a recommended way to do it. If you look at the true right website,
he also does not recommend you put the double bubble bulb right on your skin. I'm saying that,
if you are trying to get more penetration and trying to hit it harder, well, you know, you're not
going to get a whole lot more, but you may get a little bit more with the double bubble directly
on your skin. So, with the hammer tube is that long cylinder, right? The hammer tube is the
long cylinder. You don't even know if you have the hammer tube right on your skin. The bulb really
isn't right on your skin because the bulb is inside the plastic sheeting. Okay, so it doesn't make a
difference. Does it make a difference to have it on your bare skin or versus through a pair of pajamas?
I think the closer it is, the less things it has to go through, the more penetration you're going to get.
So, for most people, put it right on your pajamas is just fine. But if you want even greater
penetration, then put it underneath your pajamas. Is there a difference? Is there a difference?
I don't know. Is it measurable? No, because we can't stick a meter inside your stomach to see the
difference. But I think, yes, I think that is a factor. Now, I, I get a true rife is coming out
with some updates that I was going to say something, but I can't, because I forgot she promised me
not to say anything yet. But there are coming up with some updates that are going to come out in
February. So, that's going to be exciting. Yeah, that is. Dr. Conner is including that
the hammer ball with the crystal kind of light. So, the crystal tube is another choice with the
hammer tube that he came out with about a couple of years ago, and he said one to me to test,
well, how do you test it if it's better? There's just no way to know. So, you know, we haven't,
we haven't really used that one. It's, it's, it's more expensive, and I just don't know that it's
any better. So, I just, you know, we haven't, we haven't done that one. Donna, you had a question.
No, no, not that's a question, maybe, but going back to the thing about peanut.
Uh-huh. The things that I've read, unless you can get for sure organic peanuts,
the regular peanuts, they use glycephate on them, but when they harvest them,
they use the glycephate on there so that they harvest easier.
Yeah, I believe that. There's probably, I mean, there's the glyphosphate in everything now.
It's just so horrible, and Crystal could probably come and tell that if David is trying to run a
organic farm as almost, you know, just the fight that they have from their neighbor sprayed,
and having that roll on to their products. It's just, it's just very difficult.
Yeah, yeah, we have that problem here too. Dr. Connors.
Yes. When the, um, this was, when the update on the rice comes out,
do we get, um, do we contact you?
So, um, I'll announce it on a Zoom call, and I'm not sure how Mike is going to deal with it.
So we have to figure that out how we're going to be able to deal with it.
Um, so I'll announce it on the, on the Zoom call so that it's like, fight out.
It won't be a simple thing is just getting an update on a little disc.
I don't know because it's an updated hardware. So, but I'll find out how he's going to,
how he's going to deal with it with, with, with everybody as well.
Well, that's exciting. Exciting for me to hear.
I really, I really am, been, been very faithful to the rice machine.
Yeah. Well, and you know, you know, I've announced on others who calls for a while now,
I've been experimenting with the GB4000 in the office. I haven't said to anybody,
home with the GB4000. That's a different brand of rice machine.
Um, I, you know, I am not, well, I love Mike. At true rice, go get me wrong. He's been great
for us in baking tweaks to his product, everything that I've ever asked for.
Um, he's great at helping with any product problems. If there's any damage to machines,
you know, he fixes them, he gives us deals all the time on those.
Um, but I have to be more loyal to my patients than anybody else. So, uh, you know,
I'm experimenting always with equipment that's probably, uh, I should probably go to counseling for
that. But, um, the GB4000 is a piece of equipment. It's, it's a competitor of true
rice. I, I think there's advantages to the GB4000. There's disadvantages. Um, I think it is,
it is more powerful than the true rice. Um, but it's harder to use and it's not as programmable. So,
you can't do as many things with the GB4000 as you can with the right, with the true right.
Um, but there's a, it's, it's almost like it's, they're different. So, um, uh, we've been doing
the GB4000 on patients that have are coming here for therapies. So, if you've been here the last
two months for different therapies, we may have done the GB4000 on you while you're here.
Um, and so we're, we're doing more experimentation with it just so you don't. So, I'm always looking
what's going to help our patients. I'll be out in a few minutes. At two point three, you don't know.
What's that? At this point you do not know. I do, you know, I do feel, my belief right now is that
it's is more powerful, but at, at first I thought, wow, this is a lot more powerful. I might switch to
using this, but then I realized that, uh, not having more power, is it always better?
So, uh, you know, it's, it's, it's like, okay, if, if, you know, three vitamin Cs are good for me,
well, then I'm going to take nine because that would be better for me, right? Um, no, that wouldn't
be better for you necessarily. So it's the same thing with, with right. Just because it has more power
doesn't mean it's necessarily better. You know, hitting with the lower power for a
lower period of time can be, can be better. So initially, I thought was, wow, this is, this is
more powerful. I can tell the difference in myself, but then I started getting a lot of herks issues
and other things. I went back to the true rife and I, I've been using the G. B. 4000 a few days a
week on me just at the office, just for a short period of time. And doing the true rife
soon as I get home and, you know, all night long, um, my, my idea flipped back to,
I still think the true rife's better. So, um, uh, the G. B. 4000, I could see using it as a therapy
to like hit something just to the specific organ really hard for a short period of time. Um, so yeah,
if, if, um, if you have a lot of money at your disposal and you want to experiment with it,
you know, I have some here that I could program for you that you could play with and you could do
the other negative about the G. B. 4000. There's a strong, there's a steeper learning curve to learn
how to do it. Um, it's not computer based. Um, so that, that is an issue too. But, um, if someone is
cancerous, really going crazy, you know, we just want to do whatever we need to do. So,
there are days that the rife machine totally controls my life.
Controls your life in the sense of time wise? Time, time wise. Yeah. Time wise between the, uh,
foot baths and, uh, hammer and, uh, wand and, uh, double bubble. Yeah. Yeah. I hear you there. That's
where the, maybe the G. B. 4000 could be helpful, but, you know, you and I and some other people on
this call are the same, both that probably wasn't for the rife we wouldn't be here. So, uh, I agree. It's
better. Can I ask, uh, maximum dose of liposol with vitamin C with liposol daily? Uh, maximum dose of
liposomal vitamin C would be two tolerance, really. And most people tolerate it very well,
doesn't cause stomach issues. Um, but really you are going to absorb about 60 to 80% of that. So,
if you're trying to get 20 grams in, you're really up to 30 grams of the liposomal a day. That's a lot.
Um, so, uh, you know, that's, you know, and you wouldn't necessarily have to do that on a daily
basis, you might do that twice a week. So, uh, 30 grams of liposomal, which is 30,000 milligrams twice a
week, um, would be equivalent to about 20 grams, 20,000 milligrams of IV vitamin C twice a week.
All right. Well, I have to say goodbye as I have another meeting to go to here. So, thank you all
for participating. And I will get this saved up on Facebook right away. And, um, we will talk,
make sure to keep asking questions, send those in on the emails too. So, we make sure we get to
bye-bye. Thank you. Thank you so much. Have a good week. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thank you.